the show's moving to spotify exclusively
nothing will change about the show uh
we're going to be exclusive to spotify
for audio and video they've negotiated a
deal with us it will be coming out in
the news
very soon which is really cool we're
negotiating right now with the ceo
spotify
uh bring him up
this guy and the negotiations have been
uh his name's daniel elk
he's the guy here and he's like a bald
uh norwegian pedophile
and he's we're negotiating with him
and what's hard about doing that is
every time we try to do that he's
[ __ ] children and blowing their
brains out
uh in sweden or wherever the hell he
lives and then throwing their lifeless
corpses over his viking ship into the
ocean that being said this bald
person has given us uh a really good
indication that we're going to be on
spotify of course you know the uh
platform where they rob uh musicians who
are mostly brain dead drug addicts so
we've uh uh we said we don't have a
problem with that we especially like
that they're gonna keep robbing
musicians and taking the little drug
money uh that these people have left but
daniel eck is it acker elk
it's eck that's part of the negotiation
is we pretend not to know his name
uh but daniel ack who is a a nazi viking
pedophile uh the ceo of spotify uh we
try to negotiate with him and we get on
all these zoom meetings and on every
zoom meeting and this is true he's got
behind him he has the nazi flag and he
has so much cool nazi memorabilia that's
so hard to get it's so hard to get the
things he has
and they're always displayed
behind him spotify um but we were
surprised at the offer
which is right now
the offer is 18
billion dollars
and we're shocked at that
um he says he wants to build a new
epstein island to train nazi youth with
us
and i'm excited about that unvaccinated
nazi youth
on a new island daniel eck is it ecker
elk
ex ceo of
spotify we have a new deal
with spotify for a trillion dollars
to launder human trafficking and drug
money
through our podcast uh at spotify
and that's why we were late we were late
because daniel ack the ceo of spotify
has offered us uh
uh a deal so if we can
if we can
use it
uh in his words
to awaken people
about the problems that the white race
are facing
his words not mine
i said we could try it's not usually
what we do
spotify ceo
daniel eck asked us
um
to uh be on exclusively his platform
does that excite you at all
i'm stoked i'm very happy to be honest i
did you ever think this day would happen
never i never thought it would but i'm
kind of happy it did me too at spotify
i like spotify i like it i like that you
can't use the app
and i like that the um
the ceo is clearly in some uh nazi
viking uh cult
i mean can you not see him on a viking
ship i could see that yeah just
whipping
people
i like him
he's a good guy yeah
well
can i be the first to say thank you
to spotify for all of that money
i hope nothing we've said today will
hurt because we're in open negotiations
with him
and he like told us he's like don't
mention like the pedophile nazi stuff on
air
but it's not i don't think it's a big
deal
but that's why we're late so i want to
spotify
uh ceo doing
big uh business with us not fake
business real
business